esta vez vamos a hablar del control
endocrino
y para hablar del control endocrino
necesitamos hablar sobre dos glándulas
muy importantes primero el hipotálamo
que vamos a colorear aquí que también
está por aquí en esta imagen ampliada
esta es solo una vista ampliada del
hipotálamo y la segunda glándula de la
que hablaremos es la glándula pituitaria
también llamada hipófisis la glándula
pituitaria cuelga justo debajo del
hipotálamo podemos ver que el hipotálamo
es una estructura del diente fallon y la
pituitaria cuelga debajo de él y como
miembro del cerebro el hipotálamo recibe
señales neuronales del cerebro y del
sistema nervioso periférico y canaliza
esas señales a la glándula pituitaria
que finalmente controla las otras
glándulas endocrinas y la respuesta
hormonal de nuestro cuerpo
al ambiente
existen dos partes de la glándula
pituitaria la glándula pituitaria
anterior y la glándula pituitaria
posterior y el hipotálamo interactúa con
la parte anterior y la posterior de
formas distintas pues la glándula
pituitaria anterior principalmente
interactúa a través del sistema porta
hipofisario el sistema porta hipofisario
es un sistema capilar es decir vasos
sanguíneos muy pequeños que fluyen entre
el hipotálamo y la glándula pituitaria
el hipotálamo secreta hormonas en este
pequeño sistema y las hormonas mandan la
señal a la glándula pituitaria este es
un ejemplo de una señalización para
crina o de una señal de acción regional
el primer ejemplo de las hormonas que el
hipotálamo manda a la glándula
pituitaria es la hormona liberadora de
gonadotropina abreviada como
n por sus siglas en inglés la hormona
liberadora de gonadotropina bajará a la
pituitaria anterior y estimulará la
liberación de la hormona
folicoestimulante
s h y de la hormona luteinizante lh
estas hormonas viajarán hacia abajo a
las gónadas en el hombre los testículos
y en la mujer los ovarios y las
estimularán para que liberen sus
hormonas el segundo ejemplo de como el
hipotálamo controla la glándula
pituitaria la cual controla las
glándulas endocrinas es la hormona
liberadora de corticotropina
h la hormona liberadora de
corticotropina estimula la liberación de
la hormona adreno cortico tropa de la
pituitaria anterior
act h la hormona adreno cortico a tropa
va a las glándulas suprarrenales y las
estimula para que liberen sus hormonas
por otra parte el hipotálamo también
libera la hormona liberadora de
tirotropina o la trh y la hormona
liberadora de tirotropina baja a la
pituitaria anterior y estimula la
liberación de la hormona estimulante de
la tiroides ts h por su parte la hormona
estimulante de la tiroides baja y
estimula la glándula tiroides para que
libere sus hormonas tirosina y trillo do
tirón y la continuando con la lista
tenemos a la hormona liberadora de la
hormona del crecimiento gh rh y esta
hormona liberadora de la hormona del
crecimiento es la señal del hipotálamo a
la glándula pituitaria anterior para que
libere su hormona del crecimiento gh por
su parte la hormona del crecimiento va a
los huesos largos que los músculos
grandes de nuestro cuerpo y estimula el
crecimiento por último pero no por eso
menos importante tenemos el factor
inhibidor de la liberación de la
prolactina p
efe el factor inhibidor de la liberación
de la prolactina es un poco distinto
porque constantemente está siendo
liberado y cuando deja de ser liberado
se le manda una señal a la glándula
pituitaria para liberar prolactina por
su parte la prolactina es la hormona
involucrada en la producción de leche
materna varias hormonas de la glándula
pituitaria anterior bajan y estimulan
directamente otras glándulas endocrinas
como puedes ver fs h o l
y otras de las hormonas de la pituitaria
anterior afectan de manera directa a
algunas partes del cuerpo como la
hormona del crecimiento y la prolactina
una agradable ejercicio tenemos tecnia
es flat
que nos ayudará a recordar cuál es cuál
efe es de fs h l es de l h
es de acth y te es de ts h a las
hormonas flat también se les conoce como
las hormonas tróficas y las pondremos en
un nuevo color las hormonas tróficas son
hormonas que estimulan otras glándulas
endocrinas por otra parte las hormonas
que son las hormonas directas que
incluyen a la prolactina y a la hormona
del crecimiento la letra y de pep se
refiere las endorfinas pero no las hemos
incluido en esta lista ya que aunque la
glándula pituitaria libera endorfinas
también las liberan muchas otras partes
del cuerpo
las hormonas son hormonas directas y las
hormonas directas estimulan cierta parte
del cuerpo de manera directa
la hormona del crecimiento estimula
directamente los huesos y los músculos
mientras que la prolactina estimula
directamente la lactancia
entonces las señales del hipotálamo a la
pituitaria anterior hace que estas
libere sus hormonas a través del sistema
porta hipofisario o de este pequeño
lecho capilar
el hipotálamo también se comunica con la
pituitaria posterior y lo hace a través
de la estimulación de nervios que corren
por el tallo hipofisario justo aquí el
hipotálamo manda una señal por estos
nervios hace la pituitaria posterior por
lo que produce que la pituitaria
posterior también libera un par de
hormonas debemos aclarar que aunque la
pituitaria posterior libera estas
hormonas ellas se crean en el hipotálamo
y se almacenan en la pituitaria
posterior las dos hormonas más
importantes son ade h y oxitocina a de h
es la hormona antidiurética que estimula
los túbulos colectores de los riñones
para retener agua mientras que la
oxitocina es una hormona involucrada en
las contracciones del útero femenino por
lo tanto puedes ver todo el control
endocrino en el cuerpo que básicamente
tiene que ver con la glándula pituitaria
a su vez controlada por el hipotálamo
que forma el puente entre el sistema
nervioso y el sistema endocrino aunque
los nombres de las hormonas son muy
grandes la idea detrás es bastante
manejable sólo es una parte del cuerpo
estimulando otra parte del cuerpo a
través de mensajes químicos